of 1974 the first thing he did in in
October was asked for a 4.7 billion
dollar increase in taxes on our people
in the midst of the heaviest recession
since so since the Great Depression of
1919 40s and January of 1975 he asked
for a tax change a 5.6 billion dollar
increase on low and middle income
private individuals a six and a half
billion dollar decrease on the
corporations in the special interest in
December of 1975 he vetoed the roughly
eighteen or twenty two billion dollar
tax reduction bill that had been passed
by the Congress and any came back later
on in January of this year he did
advocate a ten billion dollar tax
reduction but it would be offset by a
six billion dollar increase this coming
January in deductions our Social
Security payments and for unemployment
compensation the whole philosophy of the
Republican Party including my opponent
has been to pile on taxes for low-income
people to take a ball on the
corporation's as a matter of fact and
since since the late 60s when mr. Nixon
took office we've had a reduction in and
the percentage of taxes paid by
corporation from 30 percent down to
about 20 percent we've had an increase
in taxes paid by individuals payroll
taxes from 14 percent up to 20 percent
and this is what the Republicans have
done to it and this is why tax reform is
so important mrs. drew your question to
Governor Carter
governor Carter you've proposed a number
of new or enlarged programs including
jobs health welfare reform childcare aid
to education aid to cities changes in
Social Security and housing subsidies
you've also said that you want to
balance the budget by the end of your
first term now you haven't put a price
tag on those programs but even if we
price them conservatively and we count
for full employment by the end of your
first term and we count for the economic
growth it would occur during that period
there still isn't enough money to pay
for those programs and balance the
budget by any any estimates that I've
been able to see so in that case what
would give what about okay there is if
we assume the rate of growth of our
economy
equivalent to what it was during
President Johnson President Kennedy even
before the the what Paul Vietnamese war
and if we assume that at the end of the
four-year period we can cut our
unemployment rate down to four to four
and a half percent under those
circumstances even assuming no
elimination of unnecessary programs and
assuming an increase in the admin the
allotment of money to finance programs
increasing as the inflation rate does my
economic projections I think confirmed
by the House and the Senate committees
have been with a sixty billion dollar
extra amount of money that can be spent
in fiscal year eighty-one which would be
the last year of this next term within
that sixty billion dollars increase that
would befit the program that I promised
to American people I might say to that
that if we see that these goals cannot
be reached and I believe they're
reasonable goals then I would cut back
on the rate of implement the
implementation of new programs in order
to accommodate our balanced budget by
fiscal year 81 which is the last year
the next term I believe that we ought to
have a balanced budget during normal
economic circumstances and these
projections have been very carefully
made I stand behind them and if they
should be an error slightly on the
downside then our phase in the programs
that we've advocated more slowly
the governor according to the budget
committees of the Congress that that you
referred to if we get to full employment
what they project at a four percent
unemployment and as you say even
allowing for the inflation in the
programs there would not be anything
more than a surplus of five billion
dollars by the end of night by 1981 and
conservative estimates of your programs
would be that they'd be about eighty
five to a hundred billion dollars so how
do you say that you're going to be able
to do these things and balance the
budget
well the assumption that you all have
described it's different is in the rate
of growth of our economy they took that
into account because I believe that it's
hard to say that the committee's to whom
you refer
where the employment rate that you state
and with a five to five and a half
percent growth rate in our economy that
the projections would be a sixty billion
dollar increase in the amount of money
that we have to spend in 1981 compared
to now and with that in that framework
would be fit they any improvements in
the progress now this does not include
now any extra control over unnecessary
spending they're weeding out of obsolete
or obsolescent programs will have a
safety version built in with complete
reorganization of the executive branch
of government which I am pledge to do
the president bureaucratic structure of
the of the federal government is a mess
and if I'm elected president that's
gonna be a top priority man that
completely revise the structure of the
federal government to make it economical
efficient purposeful and manageable for
change and also I'm going to institute
zero based budgeting which I used for
years in Georgia which assesses every
program every year and eliminates those
programs that are obsolete or
obsolescence but with these projections
we will have a balanced budget by fiscal
year 1981 if I'm elected president keep
my promises to the American people and
it's just predicated on very modest but
I think I could projections of
employment increases and a growth in our
national economy equal to of what was
expressed on the Kennedy Johnson before
the Vietnam War President Ford if it is
true that there will be a sixty billion
dollar surplus by fiscal year 1981
rather than spend that money for all the
new programs that Governor Carter
recommends and endorses and which are
included in the Democratic platform I
think the American taxpayer ought to get
an additional tax break a tax reduction
of that magnitude
I feel that the taxpayers are the ones
that need the relief I don't think we
should add additional programs of the
magnitude that Governor Carter talks
about it seems to me that our tax
structure today has rates that are too
high but I am very glad to point out
that since 1969 during a Republican
administrations we have had 10 million
people taken off of the tax rolls at the
lower end of the taxpayer area and at
the same time assuming that I signed the
tax bill that was mentioned by mr.
Gannon we will in the last two tax bills
have increased the minimum tax on all
wealthy taxpayers and I believe that by
eliminating 10 million taxpayers in the
last eight years and by putting a
heavier tax burden on those in the
higher tax brackets plus the other
actions that have been taken we can give
taxpayers adequate tax relief now it
seems to me that as we look at the
recommendations of the budget committees
and our own projections there isn't
going to be any sixty billion dollar
dividend I have heard of those dividends
in the past it always happens we
expected one at the time of the Vietnam
War but it was used up before we ever
ended the war and taxpayers never got
the adequate relief they deserved mr.
Reynolds mr. president when you came
into office you spoke very eloquently of
the need for a time for healing and very
early in your administration he went out
to Chicago and you announced you
proposed a program of case-by-case
pardons for draft resisters to restore
them to full citizenship some 14,000
young men took advantage of your offer
but another 90,000 did not in granting
the pardon to
former President Nixon served part of
your rationale was to put Watergate
behind us - if I may quote you again
truly end our long national nightmare
why does not the same rationale apply
now today in our bicentennial year - the
young men who resisted in Vietnam and
many of them still in exile abroad the
amnesty program that I recommended in
Chicago in September of 1974 would give
to all draft evaders and military
deserters the opportunity to earn their
good record back about 14 to 15 thousand
did take advantage of that program we
gave them ample time I am against a an
across-the-board pardon of draft evaders
or military deserters now in the case of
mr. Nixon the reason that the pardon was
given he was that when I took office
this country was in a very very divided
condition there was hatred there was
divisive nassif 8th in there government
in many many respects mr. Nixon resigned
and I became president it seemed to me
that if I was to adequately and
effectively handle the problems of high
inflation a growing recession the
involvement of the United States still
in Vietnam that I had to give a hundred
percent of my time to those two major
problems mr. Nixon resigned that is
disgrace the first president out of 38
that ever resigned from public office
under pressure so when you look at the
penalty that he paid and when you
analyze the requirements that I had to
spend all of my time working on the
economy which was in trouble that I
inherited working on our problems in
Southeast Asia which were still plaguing
us it seemed to me that
mr. Nixon had been penalized enough by
his resignation in disgrace and the need
necessity for me to concentrate on the
problems of the country fully justified
the action that I took I'll take it then
sir that you do not believe that it is
that you are going to reconsider and
think about those 90,000 who are still
abroad have they not been penalized
enough many of them been there for years
mr. Carter has indicated that he would
give a blanket pardon to all draft
evaders I do not agree with that point
of view I gave in September of 1974 an
opportunity for all draft evaders all
deserters to come in voluntarily clear
their records by earning an opportunity
to restore their good citizenship I
think we gave them a good opportunity
where I don't think we should go any
further
come on O'Connor well I think it's
very difficult for President Ford to
explain the difference between the
pardon of President Nixon then and his
attitude to it those who violated the
drop laws as a matter of fact I don't
advocate amnesty I advocate pardon as a
difference in my opinion and in the
courts for the ruling of the Supreme
Court and according to the definition in
the dictionary
amnesty means that that she will quit
what you did was right
pardon means what you did whether it's
right or wrong you're forgiven for it
and I do advocate a pardon for for draft
evaders
I think it's accurate to say that in two
years ago when mr. Nix mr. Ford put in
this amnesty that three times as many
deserters world-ish used as well as were
the you know the ones who evaded the
draft but I think that now is the time
to heal
our country after the Vietnam War and I
think that what the people are concerned
about is not the pardon or the amnesty
for those who evaded the draft but
whether or not our crime system is is
failed
we've got a short distinction drawn
between white-collar crime the the big
shots who are rich who are influential
or very seldom go to jail those who are
poor and who have no influence or quite
often the ones who are punished and the
whole subject of crime is one that
concerns our people very much and I
believe that the fairness of it is what
or is it it's a major problem that
addresses our a leader and this is
something that hasn't been addressed
adequately by by this administration but
I hope to have a complete responsibility
on my shoulders to help bring about a
fair criminal justice system and also to
bring about an end to the device
divisive miss it has occurred in our
country as a result of the Vietnam War
mr. Gannon Governor Carter you have
promised a sweeping overhaul of the
federal government including a reduction
of the number of government agencies you
say it would go down to about 200 from
some 1,900
that sounds indeed like a very deep cut
in the federal government but isn't it a
fact that you're not really talking
about fewer federal employees or less
government spending but rather that you
are talking about reshaping the federal
government not making it smaller well
I've been through this before mr. Gannon
is a government Georgia when I took over
we had a bureaucratic mess like we
haven't washed it now and we had 300
agencies departments bureaus
Commission's
some fully budgeted some not but all
having the responsibility to carry out
there was in conflict and we cut those
300 agencies and so forth down
substantially we eliminated 278 of them
we set up a simple structure of
government that could be administered
fairly and it was a tremendous success
it hasn't been undone since I was there
it resulted also in an ability to
reshape our court system a prison system
our education system our mental health
programs and an eclair assignment of
responsibility and an authority and also
to have our people once again
understanding control our government I
intend to do the same thing if I'm
elected president when I get to
Washington coming in as an outsider one
of the major responsibilities up that I
will have on my shoulder is a complete
reorganization of the of the executive
branch of government we now have a
greatly expanded White House staff and
mr. Nixon went in office for instance we
had three and a half million dollars
spent on on the White House and his
staff that has escalated now to 16 and a
half million dollars in the last
Republican administration this needs to
be changed we need to put the
responsibilities back on the cabinet
members we also need to have a great
reduction in agencies and programs for
instance we now have in the health area
302 different
administered by 11 major departments and
agencies 60 other advisory commissions
responsible for this Medicaid's in one
agency Medicare's on a different one the
check on the quality of health care in a
different one none of them are
responsible for health care itself this
makes it almost impossible for us to
have a good health program we have just
advocated this past week a consolidation
of the responsibilities for energy our
country now has no comprehensive energy
program or policy we have 20 different
agencies in the federal government
responsible for the production the
regulation the information about energy
the conservation of energy spread all
over government this is a gross waste of
money so tough competent management of
government giving us a simple efficient
purposeful and manageable government
would be a great step forward and if I'm
elected and I intend to be then it's
gonna be done well I'd like to to press
my question on the number of federal
employees whether you would really plan
to reduce the overall number or merely
put them in different departments and
real able them in your energy plan you
consolidate a number of eight agencies
into one or you would but does that
really change the overall I can't say
for sure that we would have fewer
federal employees when I go out of
office that when I come in it took me
about three years to completely
reorganize the Georgia government the
last year I was in office our budget was
was actually less than it was a year
before which showed a great improvement
also we had a 2 percent increase in the
number of employees last year but it was
a tremendous shift from administrative
jobs into the delivery of services for
instance we completely revised our
prison system
we established 84 new mental health
treatment centers and we shifted people
out of administrative jobs into the
field to deliver better services the
same thing will be done at the federal
government level I accomplished this
with substan
reductions in employees in some
departments for instance in the
transportation department we had we cut
back about 25 percent of total number of
employees in giving our people better
mental health care we increase the
number of employees but the efficiency
of it the simplicity of it the ability
of people to understand their own
government and control it was it was the
substantial benefit derived from
complete reorganization we have got to
do this at the federal government level
if we don't the bureaucratic mess is
going to continue there's no way for our
people now to understand what their
government is there's no way to get the
answer to a question when you come to
Washington to try to as a governor to
try to begin a new program for you
people like grow the treatment of drug
addicts I found there were 13 different
federal agencies that I had to go to to
manage the drug treatment program in the
Georgia government we only had one
agency responsible for drug treatment
this is the kind of change that would be
made and it would be of tremendous
benefit in long-range planning and tight
budgeting or saving the taxpayers money
making the government more efficient
cutting down on bureaucratic waste
having a credit lineage of authority and
responsibility of employees and giving
our people a better chance to understand
it and fold the government president
ford i think the record should show mr.
newman that the Bureau of census we
checked it just yesterday indicates that
in the four years that governor Carter
was governor of the state of Georgia
expenditures by the government went up
over 50% employees of the government in
Georgia during his term of office went
up over 25% and the figures also show
that the bonded indebtedness of the
state of Georgia during his governorship
went up over 20% and there was some very
interesting testimony given by governor
Carter's successor governor Busbee
before a Senate committee a few months
ago on how he found the Medicaid program
when he came into office following
governor Carter he testified and these
are his words the present governor of
Georgia he says he found the Medicaid
program in Georgia in shambles now let
me talk about what we've done in the
White House as far as federal employees
are concerned the first order that I
issued after I became president was to
cut or eliminate the prospective 40,000
increase in federal employees that had
been scheduled by my predecessor and in
the term that I've been president some
two years we have reduced federal
employment by 11,000 in the White House
staff itself when I became president we
had roughly 540 employees we now have
about 485 employees so we've made a
rather significant reduction in the
number of employees and the White House
staff working for the president so I
think our record of cutting back
employees plus the failure on the part
of the governor's program to actually
save employment in Georgia shows which
is the better plan mrs. drew mr.
president at Vail after the Republican
convention you announced that you would
now emphasize five new areas among those
with jobs and housing from health
improve recreational facilities for
Americans and you also added crime he
also mentioned education for two years
you've been telling us that we couldn't
do very much in these areas because we
couldn't afford it and in fact we do
have a fifty billion dollar deficit now
in rebuttal to governor Carter a little
bit earlier you said that if there were
to be any surplus in the next few years
you thought it should be turned back to
the people in the form of tax relief so
how are you going to pay for any new
initiatives in these areas you announced
it Vail you were going to now stress
well in the last two years as I
indicated before we had a very tough
time we were faced with
heavy inflation over 12% we were faced
with substantial unemployment but in the
last 24 months we've turned the economy
around and we've brought inflation down
to under 6 percent and we have reduced
the well we have added the employment of
about 4 million in the last 17 months to
the point where we have 88 million
people working in America today the most
in the history of the country the net
result is we are going to have some
improvement in our receipts and I think
we'll have some decrease in our
disbursements we expect to have a lower
deficit in fiscal year 1978 we feel that
with this improvement in the economy we
feel with more receipts and fewer
disbursements we can in a moderate way
increase as I recommend it over the next
10 years a new parks program that would
cost a billion and a half dollars
doubling our National Park System we
have recommended that in the housing
program we can reduce down payments and
moderate monthly payments but that
doesn't cost any more as far as the
federal Treasury is concerned we believe
that we can do a better job in the area
of crime but that requires a tougher
sentencing mandatory certain prison
sentences for those who violate our
criminal laws we believe that you can
revise the federal criminal code which
has not been revised in a good many
years that doesn't cost any more money
we believe that you can do something
more effectively with a moderate
increase in money in the drug abuse
program we feel that in education we can
have a slight increase not a major
increase it's my understanding that
governor Carter has indicated that
he approves of a thirty billion dollar
expenditure by the federal government as
far as education is concerned the
present time we're spending roughly
three billion five hundred million
dollars I don't know where that money
would come from but as we look at the
quality of life programs jobs health
education crime recreation we feel that
as we move forward with a healthier
economy we can absorb the small
necessary cost that will be required sir
in the next few years would you try to
reduce the deficit would you spend money
for these programs that you have just
outlined or would you as you said
earlier return whatever surplus you got
to the people in the form of tax relief
we feel that with the programs that I
have recommended the additional ten
billion dollar tax cut with the moderate
increases in the quality of life area we
can still have a balanced budget which I
will submit to the Congress in January
of 1978 we won't wait one year or two
years longer as governor Carter
indicates as the economy improves and it
is improving our gross national product
this year will average about six percent
increase over last year we will have a
lower rate of inflation for the calendar
year this year of something slightly
under six percent employment will be up
revenues will be up we'll keep the lid
on some of these programs that we can
hold down is we have a little extra
money to spend for those quality of life
programs which I think are needed and
necessary now
I cannot and would not endorse the kind
of programs that Governor Carter
recommends he endorses the Democratic
platform which as I read it calls for
approximately 60 additional programs we
estimate that those programs would add a
hundred billion dollars minimum and
probably 200 billion dollars maximum
each year to the federal budget those
programs you cannot afford and give tax
relief we feel that you can hold the
line and restrain federal spending give
a tax reduction and still have a
balanced budget by 1978 coming to Carter
well mr. Ford takes the same attitude
that the Republicans always take in the
last three months before an election
they're always for the programs that
they fight the other three and a half
years
I remember when Herbert Hoover was
against jobs for people out there when
Alf Landen was against Social Security
and later President Nixon sixteen years
ago was telling the public that john
kennedy's proposals would bankrupt the
country and the doubled cost the best
thing to do is to look at the record of
mr. Ford's administration and mr.
Nixon's before his we had last year 65
billion dollar deficit the largest
deficit in the history of our country
more of a deficit spending that we had
in the entire eight-year period under
President Johnson and President Kennedy
we've got 500,000 more Americans out of
jobs today than were out of work three
months ago and since mr. Ford's been in
office in two years we've had a 50%
increase in unemployment from five
million people out of work to two and a
half million more people out of work
a total of seven and a half million
we've also got a comparison between
himself and mr. Nixon he's got four
times the size of the deficits that mr.
Nixon even had himself this talking
about more people at work is distorted
because with a 14% increase in the cost
of living in the last two years it means
it that women and young people have had
to go to work
when they didn't want to because their
fathers couldn't make enough to pay the
increased cost of our food and our
housing and clothing we have in this
last two years alone a hundred and
twenty billion dollars total deficits
under President Ford and at the same
time we've had in the last eight years a
doubling in the number of bankruptcies
for small business we've had a negative
growth in our national economy measured
in real dollars the take-home pay of a
worker in this country is actually less
now than it was in 1968 measured in real
dollars this is a kind of record that's
there and talk about the future and a
drastic change of conversional reporter
mr. Ford in the last minute is one it
just doesn't go mr. Reynolds
governor Carter I'd like to turn to what
we used to call the energy crisis
yesterday a pretty sure government
Commission on air pollution but one
headed by a nuclear physicist
recommended that any further expansion
of nuclear energy be delayed in Britain
as long as possible now this is a
subject that is quite controversial
among our own people and there seems to
be a clear difference between you and
the President on the use of nuclear
power plants would you say you would use
as a last priority why Sir are they
unsafe well among my other experiences
in the past I've been a nuclear engineer
and did graduate work in this field I
think I know that the capabilities and
limitations of atomic power but the
energy policy of our nation is one that
has not yet been established under this
administration I think almost every
other developed nation in the world has
an energy policy except us we have seen
the Federal Energy Agency established
for instance in the crisis of 1973 but
supposed to be a temporary agency now
it's permanent its enormous it's growing
every day
I think The Wall Street Journal reported
not too long ago they have 112 public
relations experts working for the
Federal Energy Agency to try to justify
to the American people its own existence
we've got to have a firm way to handle
the energy question the reorganization
proposal that I put
a first step in addition to that we need
to have a realization that we've got a
about 35 years worth of all left in the
whole world we're gonna run out of oil
and mr. Nixon made his famous speech on
Operation independence we were importing
about 35 percent of our oil now we've
increased that amount 25 percent we now
import about 44 percent of our all
leadership from all the coal we need to
concentrate our research and development
effort on our coal burning and
extraction it's safe for miners that
also is clean burning we need to shift
very strongly toward solar energy and
have strict conservation measures and
then as a last resort only continue to
use atomic power I would certainly not
cut out atomic power altogether we can't
afford to give up that opportunity until
later but to the extent that we continue
to use atomic power I would be
responsible as president to make sure
that the safety precautions were
initiated and maintained for instance
some that have been forgotten we need to
have the reactor core below ground level
the entire power plant that uses a tummy
Paul tightness ceiling a heavy heavy
vacuum maintained there to be a
standardized design there to be a full
time atomic energy specialist
independent of power come in the control
room full time 24 hours a day to shut
down a plant if an abnormality develops
these cancer four procedures along with
evacuation procedures adequate insurance
ought to be initiated so shift from all
the cold emphasized research and
development on coal use and also on
solar power strict conservation measures
not yield every time that the special
interest group pressure on the present
like this administration has done and
use atomic energy only as a last resort
with the strictest possible safety
precautions that's the best overall
energy policy in the brief time we have
a discussion well governor on the same
subject would you require mandatory
conservation efforts to try to conserve
fuel yes I would some of the things that
can be done about this is a change in
the rate structure of electric power
companies we are now encouraged people
to waste electricity
and by giving the lowest rates to the
biggest users we don't do anything to
cut down on peak load for crummers
we don't have an adequate requirement
for the installation of homes for the
efficiency of automobiles and whenever
they are automobile manufactures come
forwards and they can't meet the limits
that the Congress has put forward this
Republican administration has delayed
the implementation date in addition to
that we ought to have a shift to the use
of coal particularly Appalachian regions
where the coal is located a lot of very
high quality low carbon cold I mean low
sulfur coal to sale it's where our
employment is needed this would would
help a great deal
so mandatory conservation measures yes
encouragement by the president for
people to voluntarily conserved yes and
also the private sector ought to be
encouraged to to bring forward to the
public the benefits from efficiency one
bank in Washington for instance gives
lower interest loans for people who
adequately insulate their homes or who
buy efficient automobiles and some major
manufacturing companies like Dow
Chemical have through very effective
efficiency mechanisms cut down the use
of energy by as much as 40% with the
same out product these kind of things
ought to be done are they ought to be
encouraged and supported and even
required by the government yes President
Ford governor Carter skims over a very
serious and a very broad subject in
January of 1975 I submitted to the
Congress and to the American people the
first comprehensive energy program
recommended by any president it called
for an increase in the production of
energy in the United States it called
for conservation measures so that we
would save the energy that we have if
you're going to increase domestic oil
and gas production and we have to you
have to give to those producers an
opportunity
to develop their land or their wells I
recommended to the Congress that we
should increase coal production in this
country from 600 million tons a year
to 12 billion 200 million tons by 1985
in order to do that we have to improve
our extraction of coal from the ground
we have to improve our utilization of
coal make it more efficient make it
cleaner in addition we have to expand
our research and development in my
program for energy independence we have
increased for example solar energy
research from about eighty four million
dollars a year to about a hundred and
twenty million dollars a year we're
going as fast as the experts say we
should in nuclear power we have
increased the research and development
under the Energy Research and
Development Agency very substantially to
ensure that our nuclear power plants are
safer that they are more efficient and
that we have adequate safeguards I think
you have to have greater oil and gas
production more coal production more
nuclear production and in addition you
have to have energy conservation mr.
Gannon
mr. president I'd like to return for a
moment to this problem of unemployment
you have vetoed or threatened veto
number of jobs bills passed or in
development in the Democratic Congress
democratic-controlled Congress yet at
the same time the government is paying
out I think it is 17 billion perhaps 20
billion dollars a year in unemployment
compensation caused by the high
unemployment why do you think it is
better to pay out unemployment
compensation to idle people than to put
them to work in public service jobs the
bills that I vetoed the one for an
additional six billion dollars was not a
bill that would have saw
our unemployment problems even the
proponents of it admitted that no more
than 400,000 jobs would be made
available our analysis indicates that
something in the magnitude of about a
hundred and fifty to two hundred
thousand jobs would be made available
each one of those jobs would have cost
the taxpayer twenty five thousand
dollars in addition the jobs would not
be available right now they would not
have materialized for about nine to
eighteen months
the immediate problem we have is to
stimulate our economy now so that we can
get rid of unemployment what we have
done is to hold the lid on spending in
an effort to reduce the rate of
inflation and we have proven I think
very conclusively that you can reduce
the rate of inflation and increase jobs
for example as I have said we have added
some four million jobs in the last 17
months we have now employed 88 million
people in America the largest number in
the history of the United States we've
added 500,000 jobs in the last two
months inflation is the quickest way to
destroy jobs and by holding the lid on
federal spending we have been able to do
in a good job an affirmative job in
inflation and as a result have added to
the jobs in this country I think it's
also appropriate to point out that
through our tax policies we have
stimulated added employment throughout
the country the investment tax credit
the tax incentives for expansion and
modernization of our industrial capacity
it's my my opinion that the private
sector were five out of the six jobs are
where you have permanent
with the opportunity for advancement is
a better place than make-work jobs under
the program recommended by the Congress
just to follow up mr. president the
Congress has just passed a 3.7 billion
dollar appropriation bill which would
provide money for the Public Works jobs
program that you earlier tried to kill
by your veto of the authorization
legislation in light of the fact that
unemployment again is rising or has in
the past three months I wonder if you
have rethought that question at all
whether you would consider allowing this
program to be funded or will you veto
that money bill well that bill has not
yet come down to the Oval Office so I am
not in a position to make any judgment
on it tonight
but that is an extra four billion
dollars that would add to the deficit
which would add to the inflationary
pressures which would help to destroy
jobs in the private sector not make jobs
where the jobs really are these make
work temporary jobs dead-end as they are
are not the kind of jobs that we want
for our people I think it's interesting
to point out that in the two years that
I've been president I vetoed 56 bills
Congress has sustained 42 vetoes as a
result we have saved over nine billion
dollars in federal expenditures and the
Congress by overriding the bills that I
did veto the Congress has added some
thirteen billion dollars to the federal
expenditures and to the federal deficit
now governor Carter complains about the
deficits that this administration has
had and yet he condemns the vetoes that
I have made that his that have saved the
taxpayer nine billion dollars and could
have saved an additional thirteen
billion dollars now he can't have it
both ways
and therefore it's
seems to me that we should hold a lid as
we have to the best of our ability so we
can stimulate the private economy and
get the jobs where the jobs are five out
of six in this economy
governor Carter well mr. Ford doesn't
seem to put into perspective the fact
that when when five hundred thousand
more people are out of work than there
were three months ago we have two and a
half million more people out of work
than were horny took office that this
touches human beings I was in our city
in Pennsylvania not too long ago near
here and there were about four or five
thousand people in the audience it was
on a train trip and I said how many
adults are out of work about a thousand
raising hands the support actually has
fewer people now in the private sector
and non-farm jobs than when he took
office and still he talks about our
success 7.9 percent unemployment is a
terrible tragedy in this country
he says he's learned how to match
unemployment with inflation that's right
we've got the highest inflation we've
had in 25 years right now except under
this administration and that was 50
years ago and we've got the highest
unemployment we've had under mr. Ford's
administration since the Great
Depression
this affects human beings and and his
insensitivity in providing those people
a chance to work has made this a welfare
administration and not a work
administration he hasn't saved nine
billion dollars with his vetoes there's
only been a net saving of four billion
dollars and the cost in unemployment
compensation welfare compensation in
lost revenues has increased twenty three
billion dollars in the last two years
this is a typical attitude that really
causes havoc in people's lives and then
it's covered over by saying that our
country is naturally got a six percent
unemployment rate or seven percent
unemployment rate under six percent
inflation it's a travesty it shows a
lack of leadership and we've never had a
president since a war between the states
the details more bills mr. Ford has
vetoed four times as many
mr. Nixon per year and 11 have been
overwritten one of his built it was
overridden he only got one vote in the
Senate in seven votes in the house from
Republicans so this shows a breakdown in
leadership under the rules I must stop
you and mrs. drew Jimmy Carter I'd like
to come back to the subject of taxes you
have said that you want to cut taxes for
the middle and lower income groups but
unless you're willing to do such things
as reduce the itemized deductions for
charitable contributions or home
mortgage payments or interest or taxes
or capital gains you can't really raise
sufficient revenue to provide an overall
tax cut of any size so how are you going
to provide that tax relief that you're
talking about
now we have such a grossly unbalanced
tax system as I said earlier that it is
a disgrace of all the tax of benefits
now 25 percent of them go to the 1% of
the richest people in this country over
fifty percent fifty three to be exact
percent of the tax benefits go to the
14% richest people in this country and
we've had a 50% increase in payroll
deductions since mr. Nixon went in
office eight years ago mr. Ford has his
advocated since he's been in office over
five billion dollars in reductions for
corporations special interest groups and
the very very wealthy who derive their
income not from labor but from
investments coming back with that
million dollars in creating a shoe
factory say in New Hampshire Vermont if
the company takes the money down to it
Linux and build a shoe factory they
don't have fainted taxes on the money
another thing is a system called disk
which was originally designed proposed
by mr. Nixon to encourage exports this
permits a company to create a dummy
corporation to export their products and
then not to pay the full amount of taxes
on them this cost our government about
1.4 billion dollars a year and when
those rich corporations don't pay that
tax
the average American taxpayer pays it
for another one that so it's very
important is the business deductions jet
airplanes first-class travel the $50
martini lunch the average working person
can't can't take advantage of that but
the the wealthier people are can another
system as well
a dentist can invest money and say
raising cattle and can put in $100,000
of his own money
barn $900,000 now $1,000 it makes a
million and Markoff a great amount of
loss through that procedure oh there was
one example for instance where somebody
are produced Phonographic movies they
put in thirty thousand dollars of their
own money and got 120 thousand dollars
in tax savings
well these special kinds of programs
have have robbed the average taxpayer
and have benefited those who are
powerful and who can employ lobbyists
and it could have their CPAs and the
lawyers to help them benefit from they
roughly eight thousand pages of attached
code the average American person can't
do it you can't hire lobbyists out of
for unemployment compensation checks
governor to follow up on your answer in
order for any kind of tax relief to
really be felt by the middle and lower
income people you need about according
to congressional committees on this you
need about ten billion dollars now you
listed some things the deferral on
foreign income is estimated it would
save about five hundred million dollars
disk you said was one point four billion
the estimate at the outside if you
eliminated all tax shelters is five
billion so where else would you raise
the revenue to provide this tax relief
would you in fact do away with all
business deductions and what other kinds
of preferences would you do away with no
I wouldn't do away with all our business
deductions I think that would be a very
serious mistake
but if you could just do away with the
ones that are unfair you could lower
taxes for everyone I would never do
anything that would increase the taxes
for those who work for a living or who
are presently required to list all their
income but I want to do is not to raise
taxes but to eliminate loopholes and
this is the point of my first statistics
that I gave you that the present tax
benefits that have been carved out over
a long period of years fifty years
by Sharp tax lawyers and by lobbyists
have benefited just the rich
these programs that I described to you
earlier the tax deferrals for overseas a
disc and the tax shelters are they only
apply to people in the $50,000 year
bracket or up and I think this is the
best way to approach it is to make sure
that everybody pays taxes on the income
that they earn and make sure that you
take whatever savings is from the higher
income levels and give it to the low and
middle income families President Ford
the governor Carter's answered tonight
does not coincide with the answer that
he gave in an interview to The
Associated Press a week or so ago in
that interview governor Carter indicated
that he would raise the taxes on those
in the medium or middle income brackets
or higher now if you take the medium or
middle income taxpayer that's about
$14,000 per person
governor Carter has indicated publicly
in an interview that he would increase
the taxes on about 50% of the working
people of this country I think the way
to get tax equity in this country is to
give tax relief to the middle income
people who have an income from roughly
$8,000 up to 25 or $30,000 they have
been shortchanged as we have taken 10
million taxpayers off the tax rolls in
the last eight years and as we have
added to the minimum tax provision to
make all people pay more taxes I believe
in tax equity for the middle-income
taxpayer increasing the personal
exemption mr. Carter wants to increase
taxes for roughly half of the taxpayers
of this country now the governor has
also played a little fast and loose with
the facts about vetoes the record show
that President Roosevelt vetoed on an
average of 55 bills a year President
Truman vetoed on the average while he
was president about 38 bills a year
I understand that Governor Carter when
he was governor of Georgia veto between
35 and 40 bills a year my average in two
years is 26 but in the process of that
we have saved nine billion dollars and
one final comment
governor Carter talks about the tax
bills and all of the inequities that
exist in the present law I must remind
him the Democrats have controlled the
Congress for the last 22 years and they
wrote all the tax bills mr. Reynolds I
suspect that we could continue on this
tax argument for some time but I'd like
to move on to another area
mr. president everybody seems to be
running against Washington this year and
I'd like to raise two coincidental
events that we asked you whether you
think perhaps this may have a bearing on
the attitude throughout the country the
House Ethics Committee has just now
ended its investigation of Daniel Schorr
after several months and many thousands
of dollars trying to find out how he
obtained and caused to be published a
report of the Congress that probably is
the property of the American people at
the same time the Senate Select
Committee on standards and conduct has
voted not really to begin an
investigation of a United States Senator
because of allegations against him that
he may have been receiving corporate
funds illegally over a period of years
do you suppose sir that events like this
contribute to the feeling in the country
that maybe there's something wrong in
Washington and I don't mean just in the
executive branch but throughout the
whole government there is a considerable
anti-washington feeling throughout the
country but I think the feeling is
misplaced in the last two years we have
restored integrity in the White House
and we've set high standards in the
executive branch of the government the
anti-washington feeling in my opinion
ought to be focused on the Congress of
the United States for example this
Congress very shortly will
spend a billion dollars a year for its
housekeeping its salaries its expenses
and the like it the next Congress will
probably be the first billion dollar
Congress in the history of the United
States I don't think the American people
are getting their money's worth from the
majority party that run this Congress we
in addition see that in the last four
years the number of employees hired by
the Congress has gone up substantial
much more than the gross national
product much more than any other
increase throughout our society Congress
is hiring people by the droves and the
cost as a result has gone up and I don't
see any improvement in the performance
of the Congress under the present
leadership so it seems to me instead of
the anti-washington feeling being aimed
at everybody in Washington it seems to
me that the focus should be where the
problem is which is the Congress of the
United States and particularly the
majority in the Congress they spend too
much money on themselves they have too
many employees there's some question
about their morality it seems to me that
in this election the focus should not be
on the executive branch but that
correction should come as the voters
vote for their members of the House of
Representatives or for their United
States Senator that's where the problem
is and I hope there will be some
corrective action taken so we can get
some new leadership in the Congress of
the United States mr. president if I may
follow up I think you've made it plain
that you take a dim view of the majority
in the Congress isn't it quite likely
sir that you will have a Democratic
Congress in the next session if you are
elected president and hasn't the country
a right to ask whether you can get along
with that Congress or whether we'll have
continued confrontation well it seems to
me that
we have a chance the Republicans to get
a majority in the House of
Representatives we will make some gains
in the United States Senate so there
will be different ratios in the house as
well as in the Senate and as president I
will be able to work with that Congress
but let me take the other side of the
coin if I might supposing we had had a
Democratic Congress for the last two
years and we had had governor Carter as
president he has in effect said that he
would agree with all of he would
disapprove of the vetoes that I have
made and would have added significantly
to expenditures in the deficit in the
federal government I think it would be
contrary to one of the basic concepts in
our system of government a system of
checks and balances we have a Democratic
Congress today and fortunately we've had
a Republican president to check their
excesses with my vetoes if we have a
Democratic Congress next year and a
president who wants to spend an
additional 100 billion dollars a year or
maybe 200 billion dollars a year with
more programs we will have in my
judgment greater deficits with more
spending more dangers of inflation I
think the American people want a
Republican president to check on any
excesses that come out of the next
Congress if it is a Democratic Congress
Governor Carter well it's not a matter
of Republican and Democrat it's a matter
of leadership or no leadership
President Eisenhower worked with the
Democratic Congress very well even
President Nixon because he was a strong
leader at least worked with the
Democratic Congress very well mr. Ford
is vetoed as I said earlier four times
as many bills for a year as mr. Nixon
mr. Ford quite often puts forward a
program this is a public relations stunt
it never tries to put it through the
Congress by working with the Congress I
think under President for Nixon and
Eisenhower they passed about 60 to 75
percent of the ledger
this year mr. Ford will not pass more
than 26% of all the legislative
proposals he puts forward this is
government by stalemate and we've seen
almost a complete breakdown in the
proper relationship between the
president who represents his country and
the Congress who collectively also
represent this country we've had
Republican presidents before who try to
run against a Democratic Congress and I
don't think it's so the Congress is mr.
Ford's opponent but if if he insists
that did I be responsible for the
Democratic Congress of which I'm have
not been a part then I think it's only
fair that he be responsible for the
Nixon administration it's too entirety
of which he was a part that I think is a
good balance but the point is that there
a president ought to lead this country
mr. Ford so far as I know except for
avoiding another Watergate has not
accomplished one single major program
for this country and there's been a
constant squabbling between the
president and the Congress and that's
not the way this country ought to be run
I might go back to one other thing mr.
Ford is so miss quoted an AP news story
there was an error to begin with that
story reported several times that I
would lower taxes for low and middle
income families and that correction was
delivered to the White House and I'm
sure that the president knows about this
correction but he still insist on
repeating an erroneous statement
President Ford governor Carter we no
longer have enough time for two complete
sequences of questions we have only
about six minutes left for questions and
answers for that reason we will drop the
follow-up questions at this point but
each candidate will still be able to
respond to the others answers to the
extent that you can gentlemen please
keep your remarks brief mr. Gannon
governor Carter one important part of
the government's economic policy
apparatus we haven't talked about is the
Federal Reserve Board I'd like to ask
you something about what you've said and
that is that you believe that a
president ought to have a chairman
Federal Reserve Board whose views are
compatible with his own based on the
record with the last few years would you
say that your views are compatible with
those of Chairman Arthur burns and if
not would you seek his resignation if
you are elected what I have said is that
the president ought to have a chance to
appoint the chairman of the Federal
Reserve Board to have a coterminous
term in other words both of them serve
the same point four years the Congress
can modify the supply of money by
modifying the income tax or laws the
president can modify the economic
structure of a country by public
statements and general attitudes and the
budget that he proposes the Federal
Reserve has an independent status that
ought to be preserved I think that mr.
Burgess did take a typical erroneous
Republican attitude in the 1973 year
when inflation was so high they assumed
that the inflation rate was because of
excessive demand and therefore put into
effect tight constraint on the economy
very high interest rates which is
typical also a Republican administration
tried to increase the tax payments by
individuals cut the tax payments by
corporations I would have done the
opposite I think the problem should have
been addressed by increasing
productivity by having put people back
to work so they could purchase more
goods lower income taxes on individuals
perhaps raise them if necessary on
corporations in compression but Mr burns
or in that respect made a very serious
mistake I would not want to destroy the
Independence of the Federal Reserve
Board but I do think we ought to have a
cohesive economic policy with at least a
chairman of the Federal Reserve Board
and the president's terms being the same
and letting the Congress of course be
the third entities with with
independents subject only to the
presence veto President Ford your
response the chairman of the Federal
Reserve Board should be independent
fortunately he has been during
Democratic as well as Republican
administrations as a result in the last
two years we have had a responsible
monetary policy the Federal Reserve
Board indicated that the supply of money
would be
held between four to four and a half and
seven and seven 1/2 they have done a
good job in integrating the money supply
with the fiscal policy of the executive
and legislative branches of the
government it would be catastrophic if
the chairman of the Federal Reserve
Board became the tool of the political
party that was in power it's important
for our future economic security that
that job be non-political and separate
from the executive and the legislative
branches this is drew mr. president the
real problem with the FBI and in fact
all of the intelligence agencies there
are no real laws governing them such
laws as there are tend to be vague and
open-ended now you have issued some
executive orders but we've learned that
leaving these agencies to executive
discretion and direction can get them
and in fact the country in a great deal
of trouble one president may be a decent
man the next one might not be so but
what do you think about trying to write
in some more protection by getting some
laws governing these agencies you are
familiar of course with the fact that I
am the first president in 30 years who
has reorganized the intelligence
agencies in the federal government the
CIA the Defense Intelligence Agency the
National Security Agency and the others
we've done that by executive order and I
think we've tightened it up we've
straightened out their problems that
developed over the last few years it
doesn't seem to me that it's needed or
necessary to have legislation in this
particular regard I have recommended to
the Congress however I'm sure you're
familiar with this legislation that
would make it very proper and
in the right way that the Attorney
General could go in and get the right
for wiretapping under security cases
this was an effort that was made by the
Attorney General and myself working with
the Congress but even in this area where
I think new legislation would be
justified the Congress has not responded
so I feel in that case as well as in the
reorganization of the intelligence
agencies as I've done we have to do it
by executive order and I'm glad that we
have a good director in George Bush we
have good executive orders and the CIA
and the DIA and NASA or the NSA are now
doing a good job under proper
supervision
governor Carter well one of the very
serious things that's happened in our
government in recent years and is
continued up until now is a breakdown in
the trust among our people in the
the podcasters in Philadelphia have
temporarily lost the audio it is not a
conspiracy against Governor Carter or
President Ford and they will fix it as
soon as possible
this debate is now within about eight
minutes of its close and in spite of the
fact that this was under the auspices of
the League of Women Voters the pool
audio from Philadelphia has been lost
momentarily we hope to have it back any
minute we don't know what's happened to
it
again the pooled audio from the Walnut
Street Theatre in Philadelphia has been
lost we hope for the moment we are
needless to say trying to restore it do
not know what has happened to it both
candidates have lost a more or less
equal number of of their words I can't
hear them either so I don't know what it
is we're not hearing I think they have
stopped because they have been told the
sound has been lost I think they're
stopped talking whatever happened we
hope to have it fixed shortly
I wish I could tell you more about it
but that's all I know
I might say a word here that planned to
say later when the debate was over and
in fact probably will say it again when
the debate is over
and it is that at 11:30 Eastern Time
which is to say to a half hour from now
we will be back here with a special
program in which we will ask people in
the audience in the theater in
Philadelphia as they leave ask others in
the area and whoever we can find whose
views might be interesting what they
think about the debate who they think
won if they care to put it that way who
they think scored the most points John
Chancellor and other members of our news
staff are in Philadelphia and will be
ready with this as I say that's at 11:30
Eastern Time after a half-hour break for
the local news across the country and
we'll be back with that whatever happens
to the audio from the theater at this
time and again I don't know what's
happened except that we're not getting
it nobody is getting it it's the same on
it's the same everywhere so you needn't
change the channels looking for it it's
the same on all of them
it's still out right Doug canker is out
where is Doug he is in the lobby just
outside of of the Hall Doug you can't
tell us what has happened there can you
David we don't know what's happened
we're as much surprised by what's going
on as you are they were talking and
suddenly they quit we all jumped up out
here too as you know
this was a pool arrangement of one
network responsible so all we're doing
is standing by just the way you are we
expect the debates to go on of course
immediately that audio is assumed but
what the problem is how long it's going
to take to fix it whether the debate
will have to be canceled or not we just
don't know we're isolated in the car to
here and the problem is even not in the
theater the problem as you know is in
the technical trucks undoubtedly outside
the auditorium it's a technical problem
it's as someone says it's not as
conspiracy but how long is going to take
to fix it we just don't know you don't
have a screwdriver and a pair of pliers
on you Doug do you I do not David no
well we've seen them I can make a few
comments while we're waiting uh we have
seen a very lively debate it seems to me
so far it seems to me that both
candidates pretty much are saying the
same thing that they have been saying in
the early parts of these campaigns
making pretty much the same charges but
very tough tougher sometimes even rough
tonight both heavy on their facts to
back up their arguments as a we knew
governor Carter intended to come here to
convince the American public that he
really did know the facts and had the
knowledge President Ford of course as
fact fell from the knowledge of his
office President Ford has strongly
defended his economic policies in these
debates tonight he is pointed to the
fact that the improved economy is proof
of their wisdom he he did this very
forcefully mr. Carter came back disputed
this and in one of the tough tough
segments charges that President Ford is
insensitive to the plight of the
unemployed now excuse me
do we have audio back now we still do
not have audio back both candidates are
waiting they have been told that they're
on the air with a picture but they are
off the air with their voices to go on
tax reform President Ford announced
tonight that he will sign that new tax
bill all 1,500 pages on it even though
he said he was dissatisfied with some
provisions that were in it
mr. Carter called the present tax
structure a welfare program for the rich
and mr. Carter also talked and so
President Ford about the new federal
social programs mr. Carter said that he
would install the federal programs that
he had promised but that should have
come down to it a choice between those
programs being innovated or balancing
the budget that he would choose in favor
of balancing the budget President Ford
said any surplus from the federal
spending should go directly right back
to tax relief both men's outlined at
great links their plans to curb
unemployment mr. Carter said that he
believed his programs could bring
unemployment down to 3% within a few
years mr. Ford got into the Democratic
platform he said that if all the
proposals and the Democratic platform
were adopted it would create 60 new
programs which he said would cost a
hundred to two hundred billion dollars
more and mr. Carter immediately rejoined
by saying that Richard Nixon said the
same thing about programs proposed by
the Democrats 16 years ago when John F
Kennedy was the nominee the two men
discussed draft evaders and what the
programs there should be mr. Ford said
that he does not believe in any cross
the board pardons he said he believed
that the amnesty program which he put
forth was adequate and that he would not
change it and mr. Carter said that he
still would grant pardon and he insisted
that there is a difference between
pardon and amnesty the two men talked
about government reorganisation is some
length and Jimmy Carter as he has so
often done
this whole election year promise
forcefully that he would completely
reorganize the federal government if
he's elected and waste no time about it
president by saying that he has looked
into the facts and figures of governor
Carter's record as governor of Georgia
and that the fact is that Governor
Carter increased the Georgia budget and
also increased the number of state
employees while he was there he also
said that the president governor of
Georgia governor Busby found that the
Medicaid program in Georgia was in
governor busbee's words a shamble far as
the Democratic Congress is concerned
President Ford a Republican president
charged that the Democratic Congress had
not really been working with him Jimmy
Carter said other Republican presidents
have found it feasible and possible to
work with Democratic Congress's he
pointed out that governor President
Eisenhower had done this and he said
that Richard Nixon he said for all of
his false I can't remember the exact
words was a strong leader and managed to
work with a Democratic Congress and
impose far fewer vetoes than President
Ford had imposed and then he got very
tough with momentarily with President
Ford he said I'm not a member of
Congress he said the Democratic Congress
are is not under my control
and so he said if you gonna blame me for
that you can blame me for rub I'll blame
you for Watergate also we have here just
stepped out Ronald Nelson who is the
presidential press secretary he's
talking now so we'll listen in what's
going on in there I don't know any more
about it than you do duck I guess they
were down to the last few minutes and
the sounds suddenly cut out but I don't
know what the explanation is and so what
happens now will the debates continue or
I don't know we were listening upstairs
on the monitor and it Newman wasn't
quite clear what was going to happen
either you have no contingency plan
obviously for such a thing to happen I
think you're supposed to be the one with
a contingency plan we don't know what
happened and I guess the president will
we'll wait and let those putting on the
debates decide what to do
well you're sitting in there with some
members of the president's
administration the Secretary of
Transportation Coleman ambassador the
United Nations scranton you yourself mr.
heartland his speechwriter what's your
impression how do you think your guys
doing so far
well we think we talked we had a little
time to talk after the sound went off
and we sort of polled each other and
everybody came to the same conclusion
and that is that it was a clear-cut
victory for the president well I don't
think anybody to be surprised to hear of
being partisan you're you're saying that
is this debate tougher in your opinion
than you thought it would be some pretty
tough exchanges in there it seems to us
well I thought the president came across
though I agree the questions were tough
and the reporters were well-prepared and
had done a lot of research but I think
the president came across to us watching
anyhow as being in command of the
situation in control it seemed to me he
had the opportunity through the tough
questions to demonstrate experience his
background his knowledge and his ability
well the same thing I think also could
be said for governor Carter at least he
was spouting a lot of facts and figures
we didn't we haven't had all of these
debates yet mr. nesland at least we
haven't had the completion of this one
humming how much time did we get cut out
on 1215 minutes do you think that some
provision could be made for the viewing
public to hear what's over what what was
left out well the president said from
the very beginning Doug and the reason
that he wanted to do the debates in the
first place and the reason he wanted
them to be done at great length 90
minutes at a minimum was because he felt
the time was needed to explore issues in
depth and I think they were explored in
depth tonight
thank you very much just his press
secretary Ronald Essen now over just on
the other side to the left is a man who
I think will say that he thinks that
Jimmy Carter was as clear a winner as
mr. Nelson thinks mr. Ford was and that
is the Democratic Party Chairman Robert
Strauss who is already talking so let's
listen in to what he say I think it was
a good night for for the American people
great night for Jimmy Carter did you
think that either man look particularly
nervous or realities
no I didn't think either one of them
looked nervous really these I thought
this they both have their questions well
wait all right
just trying to get you in our picture
too I think that they both found the
questions well as I said I hope the
president look programmed I thought the
governor Carter looked at the contrary
look responsive and they both feel the
questions well I think governor Carter
clearly demonstrated what he wanted to
demonstrate an ability to deal with
issues facing this country thank you
very much thank you
you calling winners and losers Robert
Strauss you've obviously saying that you
think Jimmy Carter won this debate well
I said this I know there were two
winners
I need the American public won because
it got a chance to see this debate see
these two men I also think they both
handle the questions well I think
governor Carter I understand we're back
with the debate scuse me Robert Strauss
now let's go back to the auditorium for
President Ford mr. Karpe
thank you
yeah I think I've got an anti NBC he's
watching eat
well we thought we had it but we don't
we still don't know what's wrong nor
where we hoped we'd have it back by now
but we don't know or do I know if they
will continue the debates long enough to
make up for the lost time so this will
be we will all learn whatever we learn
together I don't know anything the
president and mr. Carter president mr.
Carter are waiting while whatever is
wrong wherever it is it is not in our
audio as you have heard from Doug hacker
just outside the theater it's in the
sound coming from the rostrum there and
we don't know what the problem is but
but they're waiting
when you go back on
we're getting a lot of miscellaneous
conversation from various places in the
hall but not the conversation we went
there to listen to which was the
president mr. Carter of course they it
was as you've heard a pretty lively
debate each one landing a few bows on
the other though I don't think anyone
was permanently disabled politically
speaking met much of the argument was
about what new programs might be put
into effect in the in the federal
establishment in the next term
presidential term for years what they
will cost and how they're going to be
paid for who's going to do the tax
paying in the next four years whether
the rich are going to pay it all the
middle class is going to pay it all or
if not them who it is I must say without
offering any opinion about winners and
losers I must say that question was not
was not fully answered perhaps some of
the audience might be left unsatisfied
on that score on the ones one question
was dealt with very firmly and
decisively and clearly was that of
evaders and deserters draft evaders and
military deserters Ford mr. Ford thought
the government should not go any further
than it has already gone in his
administration whereas Carter thinks it
should his point was that if Nixon could
be pardoned and why not the evaders Ford
said he gave them a chance to work their
way back into into American society some
accepted and some didn't
Doug canker is outside the theater and
can still be heard from though the
participants inside cannot Doug
yes David we're here with Jim Baker who
is President Ford's national campaign
manager mr. Baker let me ask you this
did things go pretty well according to
game plan tonight tell us how the
president prepared for this how hard did
he study and was he nervous when he went
up there I would be talking to 120
million people or half a minute
i-i'll ask talked to the president last
night Doug and he was not nervous at all
he was quite relaxed he was self-assured
and from looking at him as when he first
went on the stage it would it would be
be my judgment that he was quite relaxed
and and quite confident quite
self-assured he knew surprises tonight
no surprises no I think the President
did an excellent job I think he was in
command he was decisive and more than
anything else Doug I think he answered
the questions he won't Pacific against
him for specifics he gave him specifics
again tell us about the preparation did
did President Ford sit back and have
people bounce questions to him there was
sort of a game plan late there was some
of that yes but he studied he worked
hard he worked on his preparation and he
was well prepared but sure that was
there were some of that and in the
preparation did were the questions that
you tried to brain brainstorm did any of
them really coming yeah there were some
that that I think that I think we
anticipated
very well yes what do you think posted
for Jimmy Carter of course is ahead in
the polls but what do you think
President Ford got out of agreeing to
debate after all he is the incumbent
with all the powers of office and Jimmy
Carter wasn't all that well-known well
that's very true but Jimmy Carter was
not all that well-known and his
positions on the issues were even less
well known Doug and that's that's one of
the major reasons that we wanted this
debate was so that Governor Carter would
have to take some positions on the
issues and to prevent the president's
positions are well known well then we
have a man over here Jody Powell and I'm
gonna come in with you Leslie if you
don't mind Jody come over you can do us
both okay whatever this is this is this
is Jimmy Carter's press secretary Jody
Powell who's about to go on the air with
CBS but since we were hearing this thing
all together I'll ask you how do you
think you man did tonight well I think
the real one
tonight was American people they heard a
good discussion but I thought Governor
Carter was very impressive he
demonstrated a clear command of the
issues of the facts and specifics that
were involved in the in this in this
discussion and I guess if in the debate
between President Ford and the
Democratic Congress the Congress wasn't
there President Ford won in the debate
between the two presidential contenders
is no doubt in my mind that there was a
clear advantage all the way through in
terms of dealing directly with the
issues that's in question
he was pretty tough on President Ford he
said that President Ford was insensitive
to the problems of the unemployed he
said that President Ford was going to
blame him for the Democratic Congress
did he ought to be blamed for being part
of the Watergate don't doubt him there's
that sometimes happens he said that that
if the unjust charge was made that he
was responsible for all the actions the
Democratic Congress but you've never
been apart on then perhaps it would be I
think with a bit of tongue-in-cheek
appropriate to ask President Ford except
responsibility for the previous
administration he did not at all say I
did his part of Watergate how do you
think these debates compared to 1960 do
you think they were as interesting or as
decisive there is no way in the world
that I could compare from my point of
view these debates and to 1960 I was a
junior in high school and those Kennedy
Nixon debates took before as a matter of
fact there's some question about how
decisive those debates were then I don't
think elections are decided on on one
night it would suit me fine if the
election were decided on this night now
it's a real quick assessment of how your
candidate did
I thought he did very well he showed a
tremendous command of the specifics of
the the detail of the federal government
I think he made his point directly the
comparison between the Republican
rhetoric and their record and the White
House came through very directly so I'm
very happy Thank You mr. Powell we've
asked mr. Nelson he says he doesn't know
what went on do you know why the Mike's
Widow
I don't but I'd certainly like to know
this of course took place right in the
middle of governor Carter's rebuttal and
I'd certainly like to know I assumed it
was a technical problem that sometimes
happens I asked that because it's been
my experience in a situation like this
that there's always a theory but held by
a lot of people that oh there was
conspiracy to cut them off we have no
proof of that it was just simply a
technical foul up as far as we can
determine isn't it correct not only do
you have no proof but nobody's brought
up a subject that I know of heavily not
as far as I know now tell me this I
think you know I think perhaps it shows
that everybody makes mistakes every now
and then key from the net person okay
let me ask let me ask you this I would
like that you to criticize the network's
of course because how much consultation
did you have and other senior members of
the Carla staff have with Jimmy Carter
in preparation for these debates was he
anxious about it how much rest did he
get tonight was he nervous and
apprehensive is he coming I know you're
gonna say it was cool as a cucumber okay
but tell us a little bit about what he
did what did he do the hour before he
came here I don't know he and he and the
mrs. Carter were together for four or
five hours this afternoon I didn't
bother him and knew that anybody out so
far as I know he's had two or three days
of rest I suppose the best way to judge
whether he was cool as a cucumber or not
was by his performance tonight and I
thought he handled himself very well
obviously as a would and he's primarily
had time to himself
we haven't engaged in in rehearsals and
we haven't done a lot of fancy gimmicks
we've given him time to do as he wished
primarily to study to read to reflect
and to think and
I think that paid off this evening mr.
Powell a lot has been written in this
last four or five days that Jimmy
Carter's campaign is losing steam the
playboy article the Illinois poll which
shows Gerald Ford running ahead a
general feeling well they long depressed
that's covering Jimmy Carter that his
campaign may be losing a little steam
well fortunately for most campaigns the
election is held amongst American people
not on the day-to-day opinions of the
whatever they are of the press that
happens to be covering the campaign we
have run a very active and aggressive
campaign governor Carter has submitted
himself to cross-examinations four and
five times a day in the past 18 months
in those circumstances there's no way
that you can shield yourself from any
old chosen word here there we think that
in the long run the American people
would rather have a candidate and a
president who goes out and meets them
and takes the the hard knocks and the
tough questions and answers answer them
as responsibly and directly as you can
even though he might make mistake every
now and there thank you very much that's
Jody Powell who is the press secretary
for governor Carter and now I think back
to David Brinkley I gather the debate is
over is that right the the the League of
Women Voters has decided not to go ahead
with any more of the debate it's now
1115 in the East it was scheduled and 15
minutes ago it actually ended up almost
a half hour ago because of some sound
failure inside the hall we do not know
at the moment what happened or why nor
exactly where as I have said our sound
from the lobby of the theater and the
outside of the theater has been normal
and still is the problem is somewhere
inside the hall on or around podium
that's all we know which is not a great
deal so again the debate is over and
that's it we have had some discussion of
it we've heard from some prominent
Democrats and some prominent Republicans
each of whom thought his side won and
gave his reasons why our plan is to
return to the air in about a half hour
for a somewhat more extensive
we'll be back later and in the meantime
Catherine Mackin is talking to mrs.
Carter mrs. Carter you're just wondering
well everybody's been following this
sudden break up in the debate and do you
think this will have any effect at all
on what's going on do you think husband
will just ride with the waves here well
I certainly think that if we just have
done anything about it we would kept it
going because she was just do you know
how to have any idea at all what he's
going to send in summation I just
glanced at it I've been campaigning all
day up in Texas all day and got in life
and I looked at it glance at it but I
don't know he'd have to tell you that
while you've been campaigning have you
noticed whether or not the interview in
Playboy magazine is having any effect on
your husband's campaign no I think
people are putting that in perspective
you haven't heard anything about it
tonight and I'm this afternoon
and it was just such a complete
distortion of what team explained only
out of context and I think everybody in
the country is gonna read it because
it's been so much publicity about it and
when they do they would say that Jamie
was talking about his Christian religion
too
people that did not understand what
Christianity is and it's a very good
author for you when you were speaking
with mrs. Johnson this afternoon did you
iron things out with her for what your
husband said about President Johnson not
a very good mrs. Johnson she met me when
I flew into San Antonio yesterday and
then she received me at the thank you
very much mrs. Jimmy Carter now that is
living well we are told the debate is
ended but on the other hand President
Ford and governor Carter is still there
on a rostrum waiting all we know about
the breakdown and the sound is that it's
somewhere between the microphones you
see clipped to their neckties and the
network truck outside the hall beyond
that I can't go because I don't know I
don't think anyone knows at the moment
if anyone did he'd fix it we don't know
whether they I keep telling you what I
don't know which is a great deal we
don't know if they're going to continue
the bait at the debate and wait wait for
the sound to be fixed Ted Newman is
saying something no doubt interesting
but I haven't the faintest idea what it
is because I can't hear it it occurred
27 minutes ago the fault has been dealt
with and we want to thank President Ford
and governor Carter for being so patient
and understanding while this delay went
on we very much regret the technical
failure that lost the sound as it was
leaving this theater it occurred during
governor Carter's response to what would
have been and what was the last question
put to the candidates that question went
to President Ford it dealt with the
control of government intelligence
agencies Governor Carter was making his
response and had very nearly finished it
he will conclude that response now after
which President Ford and governor Carter
will make their closing statements
governor
there has been too much government
secrecy and not a not enough respect for
the personal privacy of American
citizens
it is now time for the closing
statements which are to be up to four
minutes long
governor Carter by the same toss of the
coin that direct of the first question
to you you are to go first now well
tonight we've had a chance to talk a lot
about the past but I think it's time to
talk about the future our nation in the
last eight years has been divided it's
never before it's a time for unity it's
a time to draw ourselves together to
have a president and a Congress that can
work together with mutual respect for a
change cooperating for a change in the
open for a change so the people can
understand our own government it's time
for government industry and labor
manufacturing agriculture education
other entities in our society to
cooperate there's a time for government
to understand and to cooperate with our
people long time our American citizens
have been excluded
sometimes misled sometimes have been
lied to this is not compatible with the
purpose of our nation I believe in our
country it needs to be competent the
government needs to be well-managed
efficient economical we need to have a
government that's sensitive to our
people's needs to those who are poor who
don't have adequate health care who have
been cheated too long with our tax
programs who have been out of jobs whose
families have been torn apart and we
need to restore the faith in the trust
of the American people in their own
government in addition of that we've
suffered because we haven't had
leadership in this administration
you've got a government of stalemate
we've lost a vision of what our country
can and ought to be this is not the
America that we've known in the past
it's not the America that we have to
have in the future I don't claim to know
all the answers but I've got confidence
in my country our economic strength is
still there our system of government in
spite of Vietnam Cambodia CIA Watergate
is still the best system of government
on earth and the greatest resource of
all
of the 215 million Americans who still
have within us the strength the
character the intelligence they
experience the patriotism the idealism
the compassion the sense of the
Brotherhood on which we can rely in the
future to restore the greatness to our
country we ought not to be excluded from
our government anymore we need a
president who can go in who derives a
strength from the people oh the special
interest nothing our everything to you
the people of this country not only that
we can bind our wounds I believe we can
work together and I believe it with we
can tap the tremendous untapped
reservoir of innate strength in this
country the we can once again have a
government as good as our people and let
the world know what we still know and
hopeful that we still live in the
greatest and the strongest and the best
country on earth
president forum on November 2nd all of
you will make a very very important
decision one of the major issues in this
campaign is trust a president should
never promise more than he can deliver
and a president should always deliver
everything that he's promised a
president can't be all things to all
people a president should be the same
thing to all people another issue in
this campaign governor Carter has
endorsed the Democratic platform which
calls for more spending bigger deficits
more inflation or more taxes
governor Carter has embraced the record
of the present Congress dominated by his
political party it calls for more of the
same Governor Carter in his acceptance
speech called for more and more programs
which means more and more government
I think the real issue in this campaign
and that what you must decide on
November 2nd his whether you should vote
for his promises or my performance in
two years in the White House on the 4th
of July we had a wonderful 200th
birthday for our great country it was a
superb occasion it was a glorious day in
the first century of our nation's
history our forefathers gave us the
finest form of government in the history
of mankind in the second century of our
nation's history our forefathers
developed the most productive industrial
nation in the history of the globe our
third century should be the century of
individual freedom for all our two
hundred and fifteen million Americans
today and all that join us in the last
few years government has gotten bigger
and bigger industry has gotten larger
and larger labor unions have gotten
bigger and bigger and our children have
been the victims of mass education we
must make this next century the century
of the individual we should never forget
that a government big enough to give us
everything we want is a government big
enough to take from us everything we
have
the individual worker and the plants
throughout the United States should not
be a small cog in a big machine the
member of a labor union must have his
rights strengthened and broaden and our
children in their education should have
an opportunity to improve themselves
based on their talents and their
abilities
my mother and father during the
Depression worked very hard to give me
an opportunity to do better in our great
country your mothers and fathers did the
same thing for you and others Betty and
I have worked very hard to give our
children a brighter future in the United
States our beloved country you and
others in this great country have worked
hard and done a great deal to give your
children and your grandchildren the
blessings of a better America I believe
we can all work together to make the
individuals in the future have more and
all of us working together can build a
better America
Thank You President Ford Thank You
governor Carter our thanks also to the
questioners and to the audience in this
theater we much regret the technical
failure that caused a 28 minute delay in
the broadcast of the debate we believe
however that everyone will agree that it
did not detract from the effectiveness
of the debate or from its fairness the
next presidential debate is to take
place on Wednesday October 6th in San
Francisco at 9:30 p.m. Eastern Daylight
Time the topics are to be foreign and
defense issues as with all three debates
between the presidential candidates and
the one between the vice presidential
candidates it is being arranged by the
League of Women Voters Education Fund in
the hope of promoting a wider and better
informed participation by the American
people in the election in November now
from the Walnut Street Theatre in
Philadelphia good night